learned that Tina Turner passed away she
was 83 I didn't clearly a surprise to
you I didn't know if the White House had
any heads up or if the president had any
comment but I'll give you time to so
look that is the first time I'm hearing
that that is incredibly sad news uh Tina
Turner was an icon a music icon who had
many stages and many amazing moments in
her career very sad to hear the news I
was a huge fan of Tina Turner as you can
see from my my reaction that is the
first that I'm hearing of it and it is a
massive loss massive loss to the
communities that that loved her and
certainly to the music industry and her
music will live will continue to live on
very sad news our hearts go out to her
family and her friends on on her on
their loss